[Musique]
demandez la gazette du festival sinon
oui voyez vous dimanche sur l'autoroute
de l'ouest
arpajon chercher les lentilles alors
passons la spécialité c'est la ricotta
dans les lentilles on va c'est pas grâce
aux histoires pages on n'est pas sur
l'autoroute de l'ouest heures à quoi
qu'il en soit quand on double on
prévient qu'ils aient la famille nos
familles on klaxonne j'ai pas de klaxon
pour les perdus non j'ai donné un pot
pourquoi j'avais pas de monnaie privat
klaxons ou pas klaxons vous prenez trop
vite je sais je sais dans mon quartier
on m'appelle le gagarine de l'asf alpes
harry et vous ne regardez jamais votre
compte
j'ai pas trompeurs ya pas de comptes
l'ont géré baromètre quoi un baromètre
du grec bar aux pois et mettre en mesure
de marquer mon propre aux libyens et à
quelle vitesse roulait vous quand vous
m'avez doublé a beau fixe
sourit à bouffer je voulais a beau fixe
alors vous démarrez comment comme tout
le monde
la tempête est ensuite a ensuite je
pense à variable charia beau fixe on va
pas passer la saison
enfin j'espère vous êtes bons freins à
excellent mais j'ai pas de [ __ ] notre
âme un laissiez pourquoi bonbons l'agglo
levier de vitesse parce que quand même
vous avez un levier dites est évidemment
fait comme on ferait ch pour jauger les
sens oui ou jauger les sens avec photo
et vittek stage and would il n'est pas
chaud
six maisons s'ils s'allient pour faire
les essuie glaces salées suisse et
supporter allemand non on va tout
arranger bas de pare brise
mais alors quand il pleut vous recevez
la pluie dans visage a annonc ardi le
genre scaphandre et bah quand il pleut
sur le scaphandre samuil hublots non
parce que sur le hublot j'ai mis les
essuie glaces à bon rythme à autre chose
sans frein comment faites vous pour vous
arrêter quand je peux les sens ça ne
vous par des francs maçons pour les
trois qui vont marcher une voiture non
mais pour s'arrêter c'est quand même
plus sûr vous serez défaut deux parties
vont partir pour de l'essence mais enfin
des phrases c'est indispensable dispensa
vous me faites rire vous les briques et
marchal et 106 n'ont pas de frais pour
ce mal en point dirigeants ça n'est pas
votre briquet sur une rare pas jouer
alors je lui promets cigarettes avec ma
voiture
bon écoute et après tout vous faites ce
que vous voulez vous demander votre
camion fromage quelques mondes fromage
celui que vous conduisiez dimanche quand
je disais doublé cette fois du fromage
c'était des frais
alors si vous voulez un conseil laisser
croire que ce sont des formats sinon
vous aurez du mal à vous en défaire trop
tard tout est vendu comme fromage ou
comme phrase comment caustique didon
soit pas de facile à conduire un gros
camion comme ça toi ça selon lui tout
seul un casque vous fait dodo je tiens
le volant ou telle valeur
michael ballack pourrait vous donner le
volant pour conduire une voiture voilà
donc ça m'a permis
oui il faut un permis pour tenir un
volant à moi j'ai le permis mais ce
n'est pas le volant mais alors comment
conduisez vous avec mon père mais pour
prendre un virage vous servez de votre
permis non je me la flèche non oui
d'accord mais ça n'est pas la flèche
fait tourner la voiture dans ce virage
oui je vous dise un vous conduisez comme
un intellectuel sous développés tout le
monde ne peut pas transporter des
fraises qui pue oui eh bah il vaut mieux
tant que parent d'insister pas de toute
façon j'ai pu voiture je les ai perdus
voulait perdu oui dans une descente dans
une descente je tombais rap alors d'une
cote alors qu'ils avaient ou fait je
suis descendu voir ses verrières la
démonter mais alors comme verrièle à
démonter je me suis prêtée à remonter à
remonter à remonter dans la voiture et
on suit ensuite au moment de remonter
dans la voiture
la voiture est descendu dans la montée
non dans la descente
non dans la montée enfin soyez logique
quand on descend une montée c'est que
c'est une descente
ça dépend ce trouble avant de la voiture
serait-il dans la voiture qui se
trouvait à l'arrière puis on est tous
redescendre et de monter je comprends
rien du tout c'est pourtant simple quand
une voiture monte une cote la vraie plus
haut que l'arrière oui à tout vas tu
redescends une compte l'arrière et floch
l'avant oui alors dans le cas présent
qui nous intéresse mauvais tu redescends
des mais comme la vente des blocs
l'arrière elle descendait une montée
voilà ah oui ça oui ça y est oui je vois
oui en quelque sorte
elle reculait comment dites-vous elle
reculait vous n'êtes pas tout simple
vous un peu snob bon nom alors qu'avez
vous fait
moi j'aimerais fonder pour rattacher
moulant cette chaussure pourquoi et ses
défunts enfin quoi vous n'avez pas
cherché à rattraper votre voiture avec
un lacet de chaussure des femmes est fou
mais qu'est ce que vous allez faire
alors agir acheter des chaussures sans
lacets non non la gazette en vue journée
anthony aujoulat donc j'en ai plein en
fait si vous regardez vous deux
transatlantiques qui rentre dans le port
ah non je ferais plutôt quelqu'un qui
prend le large
comment ça à regarder
[Musique]